olivier vernet bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors à la
présence aujourd'hui des médecins
étrangers est elle devenue indispensable
pour surmonter la pandémie oui tout à
fait tout à fait s'en est fait un
étranger dans l'hôpital du
fonctionnerait pas tout simplement nous
avons fait flasher les médecins les plus
personnelles vous fait face à faisons
face à l'as à la pandémie je ne dis pas
que l'hôpital a réussi à faire feu mais
l'équipe soignante ont fait face est
chanceux ne devrions pas pu faire face
je pars est ce qu'il ya une différence
de compétences finalement entre un
médecin diplômé français et un médecins
diplômés à l'étranger n'ont pas vraiment
en fait tout dépend de leur expérience
quand ils arrivent sans expérience ben
il ya la compétence d'un médecin font
l'expérience quand ils arrivent avec une
expérience qui est souvent coupée dans
un médecin expérimenté du duc du coup
sur le plan administratif qu'est ce
qu'il faut revoir aujourd'hui selon vous
je pense que mon syndicat a toujours été
contre l'existence d'un vin numerus
clausus quelconque qu'il s'agisse par la
sélection à l'entrée de l'université en
fin de première année où la sélection
par parcours super par un quota par ars
comme ça l'est indiqué dans la loi de
santé
je pense que tous les médecins diplômés
devraient pouvoir avoir le droit
d'exercer sur les rêves d'une
vérification des connaissances qui n'est
pas très difficile à organiser
alors en pleine pandémie le gouvernement
a assoupli ses conditions d'exercice
pour les médecins étrangers par exemple
ceux qui n'avaient pas le droit
d'exercer sont désormais autorisées à
remplir des fonctions non médical qu'est
ce que vous en pensez est ce que cette
annonce finalement est en décalage avec
la réalité avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux fait pas
en décalage avec le cynisme du
gouvernement qui continue à les
exploiter complètement et qui continue 1
et à faire en sorte de d'utiliser leurs
connaissances leurs compétences sans
leur donner aucun droit supplémentaire
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
très clairement ils ont des fonctions de
médecin
finalement pas des deux médecins mais de
médecins aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
complètement méchant son grenier la
reconnaissance en termes salariale ni
statutaire nikos même temps à être
embauchés réellement comme médecin pour
la plupart c'est à dire que des
différents types de statuts pour ces
médecins étrangers la plupart de ceux
que nous utilisons ont un statut
d'étudiant alors il se dit parfois on
peut entendre que ces messala exercent
des fonctions que les médecins français
ne veulent pas faire est ce que c'est le
cas oui sauf que en tout cas de son
clarens position de refuser des
fonctions qui ne leur conviennent pas
par contre je ne connais pas de
fonctions de médecin qu'un français
refuseraient alors que fait médical en
effet faire je vous en avais des
exemples oui allô allô
alors oui je vous écoute oui je ne fais
pas je connais pas de fonctions que des
médecins refusent français refuseraient
par contre eux sont effectivement pas en
mesure de refuser une fonction qui ne
leur conviennent pas moi j'ai des
collègues
médecins étrangers qui ne sont pas
couverts par la sécurité sociale parce
que ils sont parce qu'ils sont en france
depuis trop peu de temps qui vous
entendez là ouais je vous entends
continue olivier darné en vous entendant
l'attend direct parce qu'ils sont en
france depuis trop peu de temps il était
arrivé de contracter le coronavirus ils
ont été obligés de s'y mettre
comme tout le monde alors aujourd'hui du
coup qu'est ce que vous demandez très
concrètement et dans quel délai aux
premiers ministres edouard philippe
alors personnellement on syndicats
demandent de rien à ce gouvernement je
pense que ne l'obtiendront rien de ce
gouvernement c'est une
c'est une illusion de penser qu'il
pourra faire quelque chose de correct
maintenant ce que nous demandons ce que
nous pensons qu'ils feraient correct de
faire c'est que tous les médecins
étrangers soient titularisés en fonction
de l'heure de leur demande et que une
autorisation d'exercice soir soit
délivrée en fonction d'un examen de
vérification des connaissances
merci beaucoup olivier vernet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes neurologue